head of the commission which
investigates judges in Nevada tells
Channel 8 the commission is aware of
news reports about Judge Erica bellew
and any complaints received will be
considered this is after calls for judge
below to resign by the union
representing metro police officers
because of comments she made on the
bench
we know where where cops are because I
know I don't and I'm a middle-aged
middle class black woman I don't want to
be around where the cops are because I
don't know if I'm gonna walk away alive
or not
those comments coming during a hearing
with the DA's office which wanted to
revoke the probation of the man judge
Ballou was addressing while on probation
for another crime that man accused of
committing battery against a police
officer judge Ballou sent this statement
to 8 news now quote I support proper law
enforcement what the record shows is
that I communicate with those who appear
before me in a manner that is
straightforward and understandable you
can find more on this story on
eightnewsnow.com